Joe Biden apologizes for his tactile
politics Democrats pay homage to Al
Sharpton and the Mullen report that
could be worse for Trump than we thought
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show busy busy news Tim we'll get to all
of it but before we do first let's talk
about something super awkward okay
something really awkward in marriage sex
important and some people have health
problems with this well you should get
those health problems solved it's
nothing to be ashamed about health
problems are health problems and there's
no reason to live with those when you
can do something about it that's where
our friends at Roman come in study shows
70% of dudes who experience erectile
dysfunction don't actually get treated
for it thankfully Roman created an easy
way to get checked out by a doctor and
get treated for IDI online Roman is a
one-stop shop where licensed US
physicians can diagnose IDI and ship
medication direct to your door with
Roman there are no waiting room to
awkward face-to-face conversations or
uncomfortable trips to the pharmacy you
can handle everything discretely online
all you have to do is visit get Roman
comm / Ben complete a dynamic online
visit chat with a doctor and get genuine
medications delivered to your door in
discreet unmarked packaging so dudes go
online get checked by the doctor
erectile dysfunction is a problem that
guys tend not to tackle but with Roman
it is really simple so go take care of
it right now for a free online visit go
to get Roman comm / Ben that is get
Roman calm / Ben for a free online visit
no reason to live with IDI go get it
fixed yet Roman comm / Ben go check them
out right now ok so we begin today with
a couple of supposed bombshell reports
one from the New York Times one from the
Washington Post
both about the Mullah report so as we
know the Democrats have been pushing the
narrative that Attorney General William
bar engaged in a cover-up when he
released a four-page letter which we
read word for word on the air in which
he talked about the bottom line findings
of the Mullen report and what he said in
that letter effectively is that the
Mellow report found that there was no
collusion
there was no collusion between either
Trump or the Trump campaign and the
Russian government to affect the 2016
election and also that Muller had not
actually made a determination on
obstruction of justice he had presented
evidence on both sides and Barr had
decided not to prosecute that was the
only thing right that was the that was
basically the entirety of the letter and
then he said you know in the next couple
of weeks I'm going to release as much as
I legally can under the federal rules of
Criminal Procedure 6e I'm not allowed to
release
information that wrongly implicates
people or that creates the perception of
implication without any sort of
evidentiary support I'm not allowed to
release that sort of stuff
for example unverified witness testimony
because all that does is slanders people
without us having any intent to
prosecute well the Democrats have seized
upon that to say that this is a big
cover-up that in reality the Mullah
report which is about four hundred pages
and should apparently be released
sometime in the next couple of weeks but
the Moller report in truth secretly is
actually a damning indictment of the
Trump campaign and the Trump
administration and that it really is
going to put out in public view all
sorts of stuff we didn't know now I have
been doubtful for a very long time that
this is the case simply because we know
a lot already a lot of material was
leaking out so we knew about the Trump
Tower meeting because Don junior
actually tweeted that out he just
tweeted out the Trump Tower meeting we
know about President Trump telling
people that he would like to fire robert
muller repeatedly because trump sort of
said this stuff openly like trump is not
a good secret keeper and there were lots
of stories about him going to Don Magan
who's the White House Counsel and saying
to him I would like to end this
investigation McGann saying no that's a
bad idea and Trump like okay and that's
the end of it
so what additional material would that
will there be that changes the nature of
that narrative I am Not sure there'll be
much nonetheless the media are now
ferreting out information supposedly
from team Muller about how William Barr
is is not properly representing the
results of the malla report in other
words the molar report is really really
bad for Trump and Barr has downplayed
how bad it is for Trump by the way we'll
know all of this in the next two weeks
because Barr has said he's gonna release
a lot of this stuff and Congress could
just change the law if Congress really
cared about this all they could do is
just change the law and say that we do
not require redactions when we are
talking about a secret report hands it
over to the Judiciary Committee they
could do that like right now according
to the New York Times however there is a
cover-up in place they say some on
Muller's teams hair report was more
damaging than Barr revealed well it
would be hard for it to be more damaging
than by reveal because Barr didn't
reveal very much again Barr said no
evidence of collusion also we were
provided evidence on both sides of the
obstruction question we didn't have
enough evidence to prosecute that's what
the letter actually said so not sure how
it's gonna be significantly more damning
than that but here's the New York Times
reporting some of Robert Muller's
investigators have told associates that
Attorney General William bar failed to
adequately portray the findings of their
inquiry and that they were more
troubling for president Trump than mr.
Barr indicated according to government
officials and other from others familiar
with their simmering frustrations okay
so let's break down that paragraph just
in terms of where the sourcing is coming
from it is not coming direct from Muller
it is not coming direct from others team
it is coming from people who talked
supposedly to members of Muller's teams
this is now a second-hand account being
reported to the New York Times which
makes it a third-hand account because
government officials and others familiar
with simmering frustrations at stake in
the dispute the first evidence of
tension between mr. Barr and the special
counsels office is who shapes the
public's initial understanding of one of
the most consequential government
investigations in American history some
members of mr. Mellors team are
concerned that because mr. Barr created
the first narrative of the special
counsels findings Americans views will
have hardened before the investigations
conclusions become public but the
investigations conclusions are already
public they were made public in the by
report what Democrats are talking about
are not the conclusions I mean this is
pretty bad media coverage honestly what
the what the Democrats are talking about
is not the conclusions of the Muller
team but the underlying evidence that
the Muller team provided to William Barr
we already know the conclusions and as
far as our perceptions having hardened
what the polls actually show is that
people's perceptions were hard and long
before the bar report actually came out
in fact mmm vast majority of Republicans
thought this was a witch hunt most
Americans thought this is overblown
still a plurality of Americans think
that the Trump team was guilty of
something even if they can't say what so
opinions have basically been shaped
already and not universally in favor of
President Trump nonetheless the New York
Times trying to push the theory that the
media didn't blow this entire story from
top to bottom that really secretly there
will be some sort of magical elixir in
the Muller report that will allow them
to claim that they did a great job
covering this thing even though it
didn't result the way they wanted it to
according to the New York Times mr. Barr
has said he will move quickly to release
the nearly four hundred page report but
needs time to scrub out confidential
information the special counsels
investigators had already written
multiple summaries of the report some
team members believe
mr. Barr should have included more of
their material in the four-page letter
he wrote on March 24th laying out their
main conclusions according to government
officials familiar with the
investigation again this is third hand
reporting because it is not actually
people who are on Miller's team it is
people who are familiar with people who
are on Miller's team being reported by
the New York Times and if the complaint
is that bar should have cited more stuff
in the original letter well again the
American public I'm sure is going to be
curious about what exactly is in that
Mullah report I mean we've spent 25
million dollars on it I feel like we
should know and that's all going to be
coming out in the next couple of weeks
the special counsels office never asked
mr. Barr to release the summaries soon
after he really received the report a
person familiar with the investigation
said so what so what do they understand
how a chain of command works over at the
New York Times the Justice Department is
underneath the auspices of the Attorney
General what are they talking about who
cares what the Justice Department asked
Barda released by our guest or at least
what he wants he's the head of the
Justice Department it's like somebody
saying that my producer wants me to say
something on the air that's nice
okay whatever the Justice Department
quickly determined that the summaries
contain sensitive information like
classified material secret grand jury
testimony and information related to
current federal investigations that must
remain confidential according to two
government officials
Barr was also wary of departing from
Justice Department practice not to
disclose derogatory details in closing
an investigation according to to
government officials familiar with bars
thinking they pointed to the decision by
James Comey the former FBI director too
harshly criticized Hillary Clinton in
2016 while announcing that he was
recommending no charges in the inquiry
into her email practices and this is
right by the way James Comey never
should have given that press conference
in which he laid out all of the Hillary
flaws and why she should be indicted and
then reached the conclusion that she
shouldn't have been indicted if he had
reached the conclusion no indictment he
should have just said no indictments I
didn't find evidence necessary to
prosecute here he didn't do that and he
ended up really hurting Hillary Clinton
pretty badly in that campaign because of
it the officials and others interviewed
declined to flesh out why some of the
special counsels investigators viewed
their findings as potentially more
damaging for the president than mr. Barr
explained although the report is
believed to examine mr. Trump's efforts
to thwart the investigation so I love
this so now what do we have Barry
down in paragraph number one two three
four five six all the way down in
paragraph six we find out that even
these sources for the New York Times are
not explaining what material exactly
they think bar is hiding so all they're
saying is that bar hasn't revealed all
the material which we know since bar
already said so but those officials are
not saying what is the completely
damaging material they are afraid that
bar is going to cover up it was unclear
according to the New York Times
how much discussion Muller and his
investigators had with senior Justice
Department officials about how their
findings would be made public
it was also unclear how widespread the
vexation is among the Special Counsel
team which included 19 lawyers about 40
FBI agents and other personnel so in
other words here is the real story right
when you boil it down there is one dude
who is part of Muller's team who talked
to a person supposedly and that person
talked to the New York Times that's what
this amounts to and there's a front-page
story in The New York Times not sure
that that is particularly solid
journalism particularly given the fact
that we are going to know all of this
stuff in the next week and a half like
legitimately it is already April 4th
this is supposed to be released by the
middle of April it's like a week and a
half before we find out so why why is
the media prewriting the narrative it's
funny they're accusing Trump of
prewriting the narrative by having Barr
release the findings but then they are
prewriting the narrative which is the
cover-up without any evidence of an
actual cover-up at this point and it's
not just the New York Times The
Washington Post is doing the same thing
according to the Washington Post limited
information bar has shared about Russia
investigation frustrated some on
Muller's team is according to ellen
Nakashima carol enik and Rosalyn
Halderman members of Special Counsel
Robert Muller's team have told
associates that they are frustrated with
the limited information Attorney General
William Bar has provided about their
nearly two-year investigation into
Russian interference in the 2016
election and whether President Trump
sought to obstruct justice according to
people familiar with the matter again
very very vague sourcing people familiar
with the matter well hell I'm familiar
with the matter
I mean what level of familiarity are you
talking about here gets who more of the
Washington Post report here in just a
second first let's talk about how you
can make your business better
well hiring can be challenging but there
is one place you can go where hiring is
simple and fast and smart it's a place
where growing businesses connect so
qualified
it's that place is zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter sends
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and then invites them to apply to your
job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective that 80%
of employers who post on zip recruiter
data quality cans in it through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash at daily wire that
is zip recruiter comm slash a daily
wired Dai ly WI re zip recruiter comm
slash at daily wire zip recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire go check
them out right now at zip recruiter comm
slash at daily wire and try zip
recruiter for free right now make your
business better make sure that your new
hires are great check them out at zip
recruiter com zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire okay so the
Washington Post continues here and they
say the displeasure among some who
worked on a closely held inquiry has
quietly begun to surface in the days
since buy released a four-page letter to
Congress in his letter buyer said the
special counsel did not establish a
conspiracy between the Trump campaign
and Russia and he said that Miller did
not reach a conclusion one way or the
other as to whether Trump's conduct in
office constituted obstruction of
justice absent that bar told lawmakers
he concluded the evidence was not
sufficient to prove that the president's
obstructed justice but members of the
Moller team have complained to close
associates that the evidence that they
gathered on obstruction was alarming and
significant it was much more acute than
Barr suggested said one person who like
others spoke on the condition of
anonymity because of the subjects
sensitivity so again this is third hand
reporting I don't know why they would
imply that Barr was trying to cover
something again I'm confused about this
Bart didn't suggest anything he just
said I don't have evidence to prosecute
that is a binary question do I have
evidence to prosecute do I not have
evidence to prosecute there is nothing
in the letter that said there is no
evidence that could possibly be
construed as obstruction like this is a
deliberate miss Reid of the text of bars
letter to suggest that he was
deliberately downplaying the obstruction
situation but that simply is not the
case I mean I'm looking directly at the
bar letter right now
here's what the bar letter said quote
the special counsels decisions who
describe the facts of his obstruction
investigation without any reach without
reaching any legal conclusions leads it
to the Attorney General to determine
whether the conduct described in the
report constitutes a crime over the
course of the investigation the special
counsel's office engaged in discussions
with certain department officials
regarding many of the legal and factual
matters at issue in the special counsels
obstruction investigation after
reviewing the special counsels final
report on these issues consulting with
Department officials including the
office of legal counsel and applying the
principles of federal prosecution that
guide our charging decisions deputy AG
rod Rosenstein and I have concluded that
the evidence developed during the
special counsels investigation is not
sufficient to establish that the
president committed an obstruction of
justice offense that's all he says we
don't have enough evidence to prosecute
that's it but there is no actual
implication that there's no evidence
that could be construed as obstruction
of justice that's not present in the bar
letter so ripping the borrow letter as
itself a form of obstruction is really
over-the-top and inaccurate according to
the Washington Post some members of the
office were particularly disappointed
that Bart did not release summary
information the special counsel team had
prepared according to two people
familiar with their reactions there's
immediate displeasure from the team when
they saw how the Attorney General had
characterized their work instead
according to one US official briefed on
the matter summaries were prepared for
different sections of the report with
the view that they could be made public
the official said
but so what the report was prepared so
that the front matter from each section
could have been released immediately or
very quickly the official said it was
done in a way that minimum words actions
if any would have been necessary and the
work would have spoken for itself
yes but Attorney General bars does not
have to do that
and again I want transparency I don't
want Muller's summary and I don't really
want bars summary other than the bottom
line charges and that last part on
obstruction is his decision
the DOJ doesn't get to decide those FBI
lawyers don't get to decide whether
obstruction is charged bargains to
decide whether obstruction is charged so
why would he release their report when
he's the one making the call as to
whether obstruction is going to be
charged or not none of this makes any
sense now again if people are unhappy
and they want more information out there
congratulations to them we're gonna be
finding out in the next couple of weeks
what exactly was in there but the
pre-emptive move do you suggest that
obstruction is
taking place or a giant cover-up is
taking place I just don't see the
evidence of it yet now again maybe it
will turn out that there's evidence the
bar covered something up but as I've
been saying all along every step of the
way how about we just wait I know
everybody's impatient how about we just
wait in two weeks we're gonna know the
meanwhile Vice President Joe Biden
basically doused himself in gasoline and
lit a match yesterday politically there
are a lot of people who think that this
is gonna get Joe Biden off the hook Joe
Biden of course has been accused by
multiple women who are coming out
basically from the woodwork to proclaim
that he makes them uncomfortable which
of course he does I mean like yeah
that's that's what Joe Biden does he
makes people feel weird
that's pretty much a description of his
career three more women according to the
New York Post have come forward with
accounts of inappropriate touching no
touching involving former Vice President
Joe Biden according to a report in The
Washington Post the women Sophie karasek
Vail Kohner Yount and Ali Cole told The
Washington Post stories similar to those
for other women who have already
described unwanted touching by Vice
President Joe Biden these accounts are
somewhat varied but they carry a similar
tang veil Kohner Yount said she was a
White House intern in the spring of 2013
and one day tried to exit the basement
of the West Wing when she was asked to
step aside so Biden could enter after
she moved out of the way she said Biden
approached hurt introduce himself and
shake her head he then put his hand on
the back of my head and pressed his
forehead to my forehead while he talked
to me I was so shocked that it was hard
to focus on what he was saying I
remember he told me I was a pretty girl
Conant told this to told said in a
statement to the post she described
feeling uncomfortable and embarrassed
that Biden had commented on her
appearance in a professional setting
even though was intended as a compliment
I do not consider my experience to have
been sexual assault or harassment she
stated adding she believes Biden's
intentions were good
but it was the kind of inappropriate
behavior that makes many women feel
uncomfortable and unequal in the
workplace
now again is this sexual harassment or
assault no it's not it's not okay he did
it in front of an entire team of people
Al Franken was surreptitiously grabbing
women's asses not the same thing and I
will point out to a lot of Republicans
who are pretending to be upset about Joe
Biden's behavior there's a difference
between pointing out the wild
inconsistencies in the Democratic
position about touching and sexual
assault and standards of evidence and
suggesting the Joe Biden is guilty of a
deep dark crime here remember President
Trump has admitted to behavior
significantly worse than anything that
Joe Biden is accused of doing here so
before we go off on the well you know
Biden is really he's not fit to be
President if you're a Republican and
you're like well he's not fit to be
President because he's a creeper I urge
you to go back and look at all the
allegations against President Trump and
and all the rest and stuff that
President Trump has said publicly on
Howard Stern about peeking at the women
in his in his Miss USA contest and what
he said in the Billy Bush tape like
let's not get over our skis guys I mean
let's be real about this now does that
mean that Joe Biden isn't in trouble in
the primaries no he is very much in
trouble in the Democratic primaries in
response to Joe Biden issuing a video
Conant young emailed I appreciate his
attempt to do better in the future but
to me this is me this is not mainly
about whether Joe Biden has adequate
respect for personal space it's about
women deserving equal respect in the
workplace and this is what the narrative
is gonna become is that Joe Biden is an
emissary of a broader problem with men
men like Joe bot now Joe Biden's a
weirdo I know a lot of people Joe
Biden's age I'm friendly with many
people Joe Biden's age they're people
who are a little bit you know maybe 10
15 years older than my parents um this
is not SuperDuper common there are guys
who are like this but it's not super
super common it's not it's not common
that older men randomly grab women by
the back of the head and kiss them or
that they grab them and put their
foreheads to their own or rub noses with
people I mean this is weird behavior
he's a creepy dude is that sexual
harassment or assault no it really is
not there are two other allegations that
have come forward as well the the
Democratic mayor of Atlanta Keisha Lance
bottoms on Wednesday evening tweeted a
photo of herself and Biden standing
forehead to forehead she says everyone
experiences their own as for mine I
found my introduction and interaction
with Joe Biden to be genuine and
endearing six other women have shared
stories similar to Florida's deejay Hill
and Katelyn Caruso told the New York
Times on Tuesday Biden had made them
feel uncomfortable during their
encounters with him Sophie karasek was
part of a group of 51 sexual assault
victims who appeared on stage at the
Oscars with Lady gaga that year Biden
had introduced the singer's performance
karasek said as she met Biden after the
ceremony she was thinking about a
college student who'd been sexually
assaulted and recently died by suicide
she decided to share her story with the
VP and Biden responded by clasping her
hands and leaning down to place his
forehead against hers a moment captured
and widely circulated photograph karasek
said she appreciated Biden support but
also felt awkward and uncomfortable that
his gesture had left their faces
suddenly inches apart she didn't know
how to respond to Biden crossing the
boundary into her personal space at a
sensitive moment now I love this someone
printed the her the photo of the moment
when did karasek do with it she framed
it and put it on a shelf and now she's
complaining that it was something
terrible now she's complaining that it's
something terrible the wildly differing
standards that are obviously based on a
political attempt to nail Joe Biden to
the wall I have to say from a Republican
perspective it's amusing from an honest
American perspective it's really nasty
it really is like if someone takes a
picture of you in an uncomfortable
position if you're really that
uncomfortable you print it out frame it
and put it on your shelf I don't
remember that ever being the case where
I was in a really uncomfortable
situation someone snapped a photo and I
was like you know what I'm gonna go get
that framed what a weird response Ali
Cole said she was a young Democratic
staffer helping run a reception of about
50 people when Biden entered the room
she said she was then introduced to
Biden who she said Lyndon squeezed her
shoulders and delivered a compliments
about her smile holding her for a beat
too long she said she felt that his
alleged behavior was out of place and
inappropriate in the context of a work
situation she said there's been a lack
of understanding about the way that
power can turn something that might seem
innocuous into something that can make
somebody feel uncomfortable honestly if
we are now in the realm of not the
reasonable person standard but the fully
subjective standard there is no way for
anyone to know if their behavior crosses
a line legitimately if we like I think
that I'm an objective level without us
having to know how these women felt Joe
Biden crosses lines of personal space
it's what he does it's been true for
years I didn't need to hear these
women's accounts to say that from a
reasonable perspective going up to
random women and putting her forehead to
theirs is a weird thing to do but we
were told that that was endearing by the
press we were told that that was
endearing by Democrats we were told that
that was merely tactile politics that's
how the Washington Post described it
okay fine well if in your view that is
not an objective breach of space then it
becomes purely subjective and if it's
purely subjective then any conduct can
be taken as insulting or terrible
legitimately any conduct
I am extraordinarily extraordinarily the
warden in in Talmudic he brews medoc
dick I'm extremely careful not to not to
invade others personal spaces I really
don't like having my own personal space
invaded it's not a thing for me but can
I guarantee that there's no time that
anybody in history has ever felt
uncomfortable even shaking my hand of
course not because I don't know these
people I don't know any of these folks I
mean chances are much larger than I've
felt uncomfortable shaking somebody
else's hand the opposite and they're
famously photos of me doing a hover hand
cuz I don't want to put my hand on
somebody's shoulder right but still it's
still this this sort of subjectivity
which is politically driven where one
moment you feel like I'm gonna print
this photo out and put it on my shelf
and the next moment you feel like you
know what that was that was some sort of
brutal assault on my individual space
yeah I'm not buying it now still Joe
Biden has not handled this the proper
way hey Joe Biden has not handled this
well and I will explain in just one
second first let's talk about how you
can defend yourself and the founders
crafted the Constitution the first thing
they did was to make sacred the rights
of the individual to share their ideas
without limitation by their government
the second right they enumerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
you know how strongly I believe in these
principles I've been strong and loud
about them for a very long time Bravo
Company manufacturing BCM was started in
a garage by a Marine veteran more than
two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment they
assume that each rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
oversees every component of a BCM rifle
is hand assembled and tested by
Americans to a life-saving standard and
that's because BCM feels a moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that will not fail the user when
it's not just a paper target but
somebody actually coming to do you harm
to learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm where you can discover
more about their products special offers
and upcoming news that's Bravo Company
MFG comm if you need more convincing you
can find out more about them at
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
fantastic company fantastic folks
running it Bravo Company
f G comm get a weapon that you know will
work check it out youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA alrighty so Joe Biden
is facing down these accusations now he
has a couple of options option number
one is he can simply say listen I don't
think I ever did anything wrong if these
women feel a particular way I'm sorry
they feel that way but all of these
actions were done in public there's
never been an allegation of sexual
assault or harassment against me nor
should there be because I have never
done any of those things I'm a hugger if
i invade people's personal space that is
not unique to women I do it all the time
with everybody and that's just me and
I'm sorry about that but that's about it
that's what Joe Biden could do instead
Joe Biden decides that he's going to
kowtow to the radical feminists left and
he is going to explain that he's sorry
so sorry I just don't know who he thinks
he's winning over by doing this the
coming Buddha things I expect to be talk
to you about a whole lot of issues and
I'll always be directly but today I want
to talk about just as the support and
encouragement that I've made to women
and some men have made them
uncomfortable and I always tried to be
in my career I've always tried to make a
human connection that's my
responsibility I think I shake hands I
hug people I I grab men and little by
the shoulders and say you can do this
and whether they're women been young
it's the way I've always been it's the
way I've tried to show I care about them
and I'm listed in over the years knowing
what I've been through the things that
I've faced I found that scores if not
hundreds of people come up to me and
reached out for solace and comfort
something something anything that may
help them get through the tragedy
they're going through and and and so
it's just just Who I am and I've never
thought of politics as a cold and
antiseptic I've always thought it about
connecting with people and I said
shaking hands hands on the shoulder a
hug encouragement now and now it's all
about taking selfies together you know
social norms that began to change there
shifted and the boundaries of protected
personal space have been reset okay
pause it there for one second
here is where Joe Biden gets into dicey
territory right so before what he set up
to
is basically everything I said I should
say right this is who I am I've tried to
care for people
I've tried to help people if people felt
uncomfortable I'm sorry about that but
here is where he gets into dicey
territory because now what he is saying
is that the boundaries have changed and
I'm an old man
and now I've III recognized that in my
entire life I violated the boundaries
well which is it did you violate the
boundaries or did you not violate the
boundaries did you do something wrong or
did you not do something wrong and what
you are really acknowledging in this
video is that you are pastor prime right
this is the problem for Joe Biden the
theme against him is that he is old and
that he is behind the times and that he
has to constantly be racing to adjust to
the new woke left and that he's out of
touch and here is where he's gonna make
himself seem out of touch instead of
just doubling down and saying listen
this is how I am sorry if people felt
offended by that I will try to do better
in the future instead now he is saying
well you know the times have changed and
we have to listen to all stories and I'm
an old man and this is where it starts
to get dicey for him
I get it I hear what they're saying
I understand it and I'll be much more
mindful that's my responsibility my
responsibility and I'll meet it but I
always believe governing quite frankly
life for that matter is about connecting
about connecting the people that won't
change but I will be more mindful
respectful of people's personal space
and that's a good thing that's a good
thing
I worked my whole life to empower women
I've worked my whole life to rent abuse
I've written and so the idea that I can
adjust to the fact that personal space
is important more important than it's
ever been
is it is is just not there I will I'll
change all adjust I'll change it's up to
me I'm I hear you now maybe this works I
have a feeling it really is not going to
I don't think that any of the
accusations are going to stop I think
that Biden has basically just throwing
gasoline on a fire that was already
ranging I think that when Vice President
Biden says things like I'll change
because I have to and we all have to
change instead of just saying listen I
am Who I am
take it or leave it if you feel like you
don't want me to do that sort of stuff
just tell me and I won't do it but like
come on I'm not sexually assaulting
harassing anybody
to lighten up right that would be what
honestly could somebody just say that
once in a while can people just say
listen I don't want to invade anybody's
here's the problem for Joe Biden even it
was a problem or it wasn't a problem
either was a problem or it was not a
problem you don't get to subjectively
change the standard and then determine
that everything retroactive Lee was very
very bad yet that is what his Democratic
rivals are doing they're doing it on the
fly and it really is it really is
unpleasant to watch just on an objective
level beta O'Rourke for example saying
listen what we need to do we need to
listen to all the stories how about if
Joe Biden said listen if you felt
uncomfortable I'm sorry that's it if you
felt uncomfortable I'm sorry end of
story
you didn't accuse me of sexual assault
or harassment that's it that's the whole
thing instead it's we have to listen to
their stories we have to talk about how
women are made to feel and cook why do
we have to talk about women generally
being made to feel uncomfortable really
I don't understand why everything turns
into a generalized conversation about
women being made to feel uncomfortable
when this was a specific conversation
about a specific guy doing specifically
weird things like I'm not doing any of
these things and there's this tendency
in the media whenever that a Democrat
does something bad it requires us to do
a generalized conversation that
reinforces their narrative notice which
incidents require a generalized
conversation it's all the incidents that
reinforce a particular Democratic
narrative a particularly left-leaning
progressive narrative if we were talking
about something that didn't reinforce
that narrative we wouldn't be pushing it
very hard here's beta Rock reinforcing
the narrative in the hopes of winning
over suburban women in the primaries I
think we listen to those who are raising
their stories who have the courage to
come forward to share their experience
and also to be part of the conversation
about either his candidacy or how he
fares as a a contender for the
nomination if he if he jumps in so I
think ultimately that's going to be a
decision for him to make okay um yeah
the idea we're gonna push him out of the
race because we have to listen to
everybody source okay how about if we
listen to somebody's story and then we
go yeah I think that you're not really
suffering very much like are we allowed
to say that because if you printed out a
photo of a person
and doing something so terrible to you
and then framed it and put it on your
desk I'm gonna go with you didn't suffer
all that much can we not pretend that
this is some sort of sexual-assault
survival story because it isn't it's
it's it's it's irritating now the person
who could save Joe Biden from all of
this is of course standing over here in
the wings and like Rorschach he looks
down and says no we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
cybercrime admit you think cybercrime is
something that happens to other people
you may think no one wants your data or
that hackers can't grab your passwords
or credit card details you would be
wrong the stealing data from
unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi was
one of the simplest cheapest ways for
hackers to make money when you leave
your internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your passwords
and credit card numbers on a huge
billboard for the rest of the world to
see that's why I decided to take action
to protect myself from cyber criminals I
use Express VPN expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address expressvpn has
easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly in
the background of your computer phone
and tablet turning on expressvpn
protection well that only takes one
click using expressvpn I can safely surf
on public Wi-Fi without being snooped on
or having my personal data stolen for
less than seven bucks a month you can
get the same expressvpn protection that
I have expressvpn is rated the number
one VPN service by TechRadar and comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee
protect your online activity today find
out how you can get three months for
free and expressvpn comm slash pen that
is expr ESS VPN comm slash ban for 3
months free with a one-year package that
is expressed VPN calm / pen to learn
more expressive VPN calm / man go check
them out right now in just a second
we are going to get to the one person
who could save Biden from himself here
and will not do so and the Democrats kow
telling to one of the worst people in
the history of modern American politics
will get to all that in just a second
first you have to subscribe go over to
daily wire comm for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to daily wire
comm when you do you don't just get this
show you also get everybody else is
shaking it Andrew Clavin show and Matt
Walsh is showing Michael moles is show
and you get two additional hours of me
every afternoon when you get the annual
subscription you get all sorts of
goodies - first of all I get the leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr it is also it
is also cheaper than the monthly
subscription go check that out right now
and our Sundays specials become Saturday
specials I'm particularly excited about
this week's Sunday special which
features the
kradic presidential candidate andrew
gang who had the bravery to actually
walk in a studio and have you know a
normal conversation with someone who
disagrees with some of the things he
says I know it's crazy man so go check
that out when you become a subscriber
there's also additional material behind
the paywall for these Sunday specials as
well also subscribe over at youtube or
itunes if you want some additional fun
go check out Joe Rogan Joe I was on Joe
Rogan's show yesterday we had about a
two and a half hour conversation on
everything ranging from social media
censorship to gay marriage to pot to the
use of psychedelic drugs in the burning
bush in the Bible there's it there's a
lot there you can go check that out as
well we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so there's there's one person who could
save Joe Biden from himself here could
step in and just say guys calm it down
we all know Joe Biden's not a sexual
harasser he's not a sexual assault or we
all know Joe is huggy but can we just
like cool your jets for a second here
he's sorry if he offended anybody but
let's be real about this that person is
former President Barack Obama who's been
utterly silent throughout all of this
other 20 20 presidential candidates have
spoken about it so his Speaker Nancy
Pelosi however Obama hasn't been quoted
in a single report
he's tweeted no expression of support
for Biden why because the truth is the
Barack Obama is out to protect Barack
Obama he's not out there to protect his
former VP the hits against the 76 year
old are designed to make him seem past
his prime and done the only person who
could save him at this point is Obama
Obama saluted Biden as a brother in his
farewell address as the Washington free
beacon points out but it's more like see
you later brother
then oh look my brother is running for
president of the United States
so Barack Obama is sitting this one out
as honestly I sort of expected he would
and I think most observers expected him
to do meanwhile Democrats like I have
such trouble with a Democratic Party
that finds it significantly more
troubling and offensive that Joe Biden
publicly was was putting his forehead to
other women's and men's foreheads they
find that more troubling than the fact
that every single major Democrat showed
up to pay homage to one of the worst
racial hoaxsters in American history I'm
speaking of course about Al Sharpton who
is just a bag of human debris I mean
he's just a terrible person al Sharpton
al Sharpton in 1987 completely
fabricated a rape hoax about Tawana
Brawley hey this is no it was
significantly worse by the way than
Jesse Smollett
he actually fingered an individual human
being named Stephen Pagonis case even
Pagonis was the prosecutor he suggested
that he was responsible for raping
kidnapping and writing racial slurs in
feces on the body of a 15 year old black
girl Pagonis ended up winning a slander
lawsuit against Sharpton Sharpton never
paid what he owed
begoña's said quote I view Al Sharpton
as being nothing more than an
opportunist in a race baiter when I hope
the networks and advertisers would push
would be for sharpton to admit that he
now knows that Pagonis and other
individuals he lied about had nothing to
do with whatever happened to Bradley
Bradley it turns out had not actually
been raped or kidnapped or anything like
that it had all been staged al sharpton
is the guy who helped initiate the Crown
Heights riots in 1991 there's a Hasidic
Jew who accidentally killed a young
black kid in a car accident so Sharpton
headed on over to Crown Heights a
heavily Jewish neighborhood where he
spoke at the funeral and there he said
that diamond merchants had the blood of
innocent babies on their hands and said
quote if the Jews want to get it on
tell them have him back there yarmulkes
and come over to my house then there are
riots that ended with the death of
Yankel Rosenbaum an Orthodox Jewish
student Rosenbaum ins brother said his
never apologised he's never offered any
sincere remorse for the atrocious things
he has done by way of terrible racist
behavior and lies for inciting racial
events in 1995 al Sharpton helped
initiate an actual arson attack at
Freddie's fashion Mart Freddie's fashion
Mart had raised its own rent by a
Freddie's Fatima had raised rent on a
black owned music store that was in the
fashion Mart because it had had its own
rent raised by a black landlord in
Harlem that did not stop Sharpton from
blaming Freddie's fashion Mart and
accusing them of racism he said quote we
will not stand by and allow them to move
this brother so that some white
interloper can expand his business
protesters said that that particular
event were shouting burned down the Jews
store one of the protesters then shot
for employees of Freddie's fashion Mart
and set the store on fire and then of
course you'll recall that after the Duke
lacrosse players were accused of raping
a stripper named crystal Mangum Sharpton
showed up ready to battle he said I
think when you look at the racial
atmosphere when you look at the fact
that there again were the allegations of
racial statements when you look at a lot
of the people feeling they've been
treated differently where this girl has
basically had a character charged in the
media there's a lot of racism that's in
the air Mangum was not only lying she
was later convicted of murdering her
boyfriend
I mean Sharpton is one of the worst
racial actors in America and all he does
he shakedown companies he accuses them
of racism and then if they give a
donation to the National Action Network
from which he pays himself a nice salary
then he says oh look they've been cured
of racism magical so Democrats naturally
show up to pay homage to this bag of
garbage he's just a bad person now
Sharpton I mean really a bad guy and
al Sharpton I guess his National Action
Network has become a Waystation
probably's Democratic nominees so let's
get this straight they wouldn't show up
at AIPAC they wouldn't show up at the
American Israel Public Affairs Committee
because if they did if they showed up at
that public affairs conference and spoke
in front of the Druze than to many
members of the progressive base would be
upset but if they show up and speak in
front of Al Sharpton as they have been
doing every year for years then this is
seen as some sort of woke
intersectionality off a dozen Democratic
candidates for president showed up at
the National Action Network where the
smartest of these folks pander directly
to Al Sharpton with race-based Appeals
this is why I think bata O'Rourke is
still a sleeper guys and I keep
dismissing bado because I mean he's a
joke I mean they know rides around on a
skateboard with the bangs in his eyes
and and it's all weird and eats New
Mexican dirt and all that but the truth
is that our work is more astute a
politician at least in store in in terms
of her straightforward retail politics
than a lot of his associate
here's beta O'Rourke yesterday at the
National Action Network standing
alongside al Sharpton and explaining he
wants a commission on reparations
yes foundational reparations is the word
preparer foundational to repair is the
truth and until all Americans understand
their civil rights for not just those he
such a middle school debater beta
O'Rourke did you know that the
foundation of reparations is repair Wow
thank you beta O'Rourke for that
insightful etymology of the word
reparations that is clear from the
actual word reparations and the
foundation of repairing is the truth
well I mean the depth of this person but
obviously he is there because he's
hoping to win an outside share of the
black vote particularly as Joe Biden
goes down right now Joe Biden is the
person who's carrying the plurality of
the black vote better work didn't stop
there he also suggested that mass
incarceration was a huge problem in the
United States now I'm not a big fan of
the mass incarceration argument because
I keep wondering who are the guilty who
are the innocent people who have been
jailed for no reason at all now you can
say that you want to change the drug
laws but and and very frankly I'm in
favor of changing a lot of the drug laws
but the vast majority of people in
prison are not in prison for mere
possession of marijuana this mass
incarceration argument that the police
are going around willy-nilly arresting
innocent people is just nonsense they
don't work says it at the National
Action Network no cuz you know that's
what he's doing
[Music]
[Applause]
so I don't even know what that means
it's not a problem of our police or our
courts it's not even the criminal
justice system or the cops according to
mate or work it's all of us it's in our
hearts
I'm telling you Bader work that guy is
going to appeal on the basis level to
every member of the progressive
coalition he's still dangerous I'll tell
you who's gonna have trouble though the
person who's going to have a little more
trouble than she thinks she's going to
have is Kamala Harris Andrew Kaczynski
at CNN has been doing really solid work
digging up material on some of these
Democratic candidates because it's
actually newsworthy he has a piece today
about Camille Harris says Kamala Harris
as District Attorney fought public
defenders in push for higher bails for
gun crimes
the problem for Kamala Harris is that in
the perspective of many in the
progressive wolf base she's too much of
a narc to win as District Attorney of
San Francisco Kamala Harris supported
higher bail amounts on gun related
charges sparking a fight with the city's
public defender and defense attorneys
who argued that the measures would
disproportionately affect the poor but
in her career on the national level
Harris has sought to address the
disproportionate impact of cash bail on
poor defendants she's made reducing the
burden of bail a part of her 2020
Democratic presidential campaign and
Senate tenure in July 2017 she
introduced legislation with Rand Paul to
encourage changes or replacement of the
cash bail system she said it was long
past time to address bail reform across
the country but that was not the case
when she was actually a district
attorney she says that she once viewed
higher bail amounts as a way to fight
what she said was a public safety issue
she argued that San Francisco's low bail
meant that criminals traveled to the
city to commit crime because the
punishment there was cheaper than the
surrounding counties Harris's
presidential campaign spokesperson Ian
Sam's told Kay file that Harris was
responding to an increase in gun
homicides and illegal guns in the city
and that her efforts today still take
into account the threat a defendant
poses when considering bail well if
that's the case if the idea is that when
crime accelerates the commo harris is
gonna step in and raise cash bail but
she's in favor of actual law and order
that isn't going to play that is gonna
play all that well this is why I think
that Kamala Harris may be in trouble as
a candidate to a lot of talk early on
about Kamala Harris being the sort of de
facto Democratic frontrunner I'm not
sure that's gonna play out the way that
commonly Harris thinks it is she doesn't
have that same progressive support that
O'Rourke does and she's not raising the
kind of money frankly the beta O'Rourke
is I mean como Harris has raised
something like 12 million dollars so far
mineral rook raised that in about
one-third the time you raise nine point
four million dollars in about one-third
the time so I'm not sure that this is
gonna play out exactly how how come will
Harris wants it to play out suffice it
to say one of the uglier aspects of our
election of our electioneering is the
sort of pandering that you are seeing at
the National Action Network where you
can say things that are patently untrue
so long as they please the audience this
by the way is not unique to the National
Action Network of course this is true
for virtually every political crowd you
go there any pander to them the bravest
politicians are the ones who actually go
to places and then say things that are
unpopular to the crowd well Stacey
Abrams wasn't doing that yesterday she
continues to maintain that she might run
for president herself on the basis of
her losing a Georgia gubernatorial race
baiter O'Rourke has never held an office
higher than House of Representatives
that's a step higher than Stacey Abrams
who's never held an office outside the
Georgia House of Representatives now she
says she might run for president over at
the National Action Network and she is
still claiming that she won her election
in Georgia despite losing by 50,000
votes in Georgia no you didn't know you
in fact did not again it's very
convenient to go to two different places
around the country to your supporters
and just say what they want to hear the
fact that people are doing that for Al
Sharpton is pretty astonishing I think
that the the there is something humorous
about some of these fringe candidates
trying to do this routine Bill DeBlasio
continues to pretend that people want
him to run for president despite the
fact that legitimately no one wants him
to run for president there's something
perverse about the mayor of New York
sitting in for Anning in front of the al
Sharpton while talking about
redistributing wealth I mean it's boy
here is Bill DeBlasio the Communist
mayor of New York we have a chance to
talk about the fact that our country for
so many people is going in the wrong
direction but don't let people tell you
can't afford to fix these problems don't
let people tell you we cannot afford to
take care of working families it's not
for lack of money there is plenty of
money in this world there is plenty of
money in this nation it's just in the
wrong hands okay that's that's really
the problem if we could just give the
money to Al Sharpton you know through
payoffs if we could just ensure that
that al Sharpton got more money at the
National Action Network if we could just
make sure that the city government of
New York was leveraged to investigate
every allegation made by Al Sharpton but
never to investigate al Sharpton himself
that would probably be the best way to
do all of this our politics are getting
uglier they are not fact-based
the fact that al Sharpton is still
considered a mainstream figure is
perfect evidence of that if al Sharpton
were a white guy who pulled the same
kind of crap that al Sharpton has pulled
over his career there's a high
likelihood that not only would he not be
in politics he would be facing
significant criminal liability for all
the stuff that he's done over the course
of his career okay time for some things
I like and then some things that I hate
so things that I like so there's a movie
that I recommended earlier this week
called the highwayman it's really good
it's with Kevin Costner and Woody
Harrelson and it's about the cops who
the Texas Rangers who hunted down and
killed Bonnie and Clyde when the movie
is really great specifically because it
shows that Bonnie and Clyde were
actually evil sociopaths which they were
and there are a lot of critics who are
angry at the highway men they were angry
because it blew up the mythos of Bonnie
and Clyde that was created by a film
that was made back in the 1970s 1960s
I believe 1970s early 70s which was
called Bonnie and Clyde with Warren
Beatty and Faye Dunaway in which crime
was romanticized as a sort of
redistributionist socialism I mean the
tagline for the film was they're young
they're in love they rob banks and they
were these young beautiful people in
love happy and society was sort of just
harming them and so they decided to
randomly murder people and shoot cops
and robbed banks the movie is it's a
great movie it really is a good movie it
also features the first performances of
both Gene Hackman I believe as well as
as well as Gene Wilder gene Wilder shows
up for a little while and is very funny
here's a little bit of preview
cost like two hot wires they lured off
on what might easily have been a wild
romantic lark almost before they knew it
with the giggles still in their ears
they had bloodied up four state
[Music]
so this came out in 1967 the movie was
deeply effective in romanticizing crime
and suggesting that crime was actually
just a romantic a romantic socialist
redistribution of scheme and the and so
there are a lot of critics are very
angry at the Highwaymen because the
Highwaymen dis abuses people of this
notion and points out and it really just
I mean it really destroys the narrative
of Bonnie and Clyde and there's a line
where one of the where this this gas
station attendant says something to
Kevin Costner about how Bonnie and Clyde
are just robbing banks and banks ones
who have hurt me and Kevin Costner says
they shot a gas station they shot a gas
station attendant over $4 in the face oh
that's really who Bonnie and Clyde were
but it's an important movie in sort of
the history of cinema also the use of
violence is romanticized and made and
it's slow-motion and very graphic at the
time it was extraordinarily
controversial it did lead to this wave
of new movies that that made crime into
something glorious in the late 60s and
early 70s as part of the cultural
zeitgeist and so for that reason it's
sort of an important film even though it
is a pack of lies about who Bonnie and
Clyde actually were okay time for a
quick thing that I hate so Chelsea
Clinton is now explaining how she
explains global warming to her
five-year-old she was on the view why is
everyone get booked on the view except
me I mean I guess it's just jealousy
that I don't get booked on with you at
this point but my goodness guys I mean
what do I have to do either the number
one New York Times best-selling book
last week it's still the number three
New York Times best-selling book this
week like we have a pretty popular
podcast guys is it too much cat in any
case I don't have to openly appeal for
your sympathy hey guys
Chelsea Clinton was on the view and
there she explained that she's already
teaching her small children about global
warming your kids are still very young
at what age do you start talking to them
about serious issues like climate change
so we're already talking about it I mean
we talk about climate change and we talk
about kind of why we make the choices we
make at home
to recycle our kids like help take out
the recycling yeah they're 2 & 4 but
they can carry cardboard boxes they're
recycling
our daughter now helps us think we're
changing the light bulbs and we talk
about why we're using energy conscious
light bulbs and they may not understand
all those words mine but I hope that by
talking about these kind of big issues
in a way they hopefully do you
understand excuse me at home early on
they'll not only appreciate why we're
making those choices but make those
choices themselves because they grow up
okay so here's here's my only problem
with all of this does this shade over
like this is this what she's actually
saying here is not terrible right I mean
the idea that she make certain choices
at home we have to explain to our kids
why we're doing that don't really have a
problem with that my problem is when the
media shades stuff like that over into
something broader which is we have to
indoctrinate five-year-olds in the green
New Deal and then those kids Trump and
Diane Feinstein's office and harass them
so my problem is now with Chelsea
Clinton who it seems by the way Chelsea
Clinton seems like a perfectly
reasonable and somewhat charming young
person I know this is an unpopular point
of view but I mean she will speak truth
sometimes to people in her own party
which is something that I admire with
that said the the kind of push that we
are supposed to indoctrinate our
children in political matters that
really have no relevance to home life
that's something I'm uncomfortable with
even if I think Chelsea Clinton is not
doing anything particularly wrong right
there okay we'll be back a little bit
later today with two more hours of the
bench beer so one quick correction from
yesterday I mentioned in the roadmap to
2020 episode yesterday that Donald Trump
had to win two of the following three
states Wisconsin Pennsylvania or
Michigan plus all the states he won last
time in order for him to when they win
the election that's not true he has to
in one of those three states he has to
maintain Florida has to maintain Ohio
and all the other states he needs to win
to get to 270 either at Wisconsin or
Michigan or Pennsylvania which means he
does have a path Democrats the the over
the overarching critique however is
correct the Democrats by moving far to
the left are coming much closer to
handing Trump the election already we'll
be back here later today or we will see
you here tomorrow make sure to go pick
up in a copy of my new book the right
side of history continues to chart at
the New York Times number three on your
Times bestseller list who is number one
last week so go check that out right now
at Amazon check out my interview that I
did with the Joe Rogan as well if you
have some extra time on the Internet
today there's a lot of fun Joe's awesome
and we will see a little bit later i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua ov era
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey it's Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show the Democrat press is
at it again trying to make a scandal
where no scandal exists but is a wholly
Democrat press actually good for the
Democrats we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin